Hi everyone. Welcome to toxic
Google. Uh, I'm Chalmers Brown.
For those of you who don't know me,
I'm a business systems analyst and
our corporate engineering area. Uh,
I now work on our Corp to cloud project,
but for most of my five plus
years here at Google, uh,
I've been working alongside
our people operations team, uh,
building out systems like
g, hire a perf and grow. Um,
today's event is called Hustle Times
heart, the silver lining of work culture.
Uh, and we are honored to be joined
by Claude Silver Vaynermedia.
His inaugural role.
Yeah,
intermediate.
His inaugural chief heart officer,
a first of its kind position created to
scale the company's people. First Ethos,
a club champions, empathy
driven leadership is she
overseas talent management,
employee experience and recruitment
for over 750 employees at Vayner media,
which is a Gary Vaynerchuk company.
Uh,
for those of you who
might not be familiar,
a Gary Vaynerchuk is a serial
entrepreneur and the CEO and Co founder of
Vaynermedia,
which is a full service digital agency
serving fortune 500 clients across the
companies four locations.
Uh,
and Gary is also the host of a widely
successful ask Gary Vee show on Youtube.
I think he has a really popular channel.
I think it's now Gary V. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh,
Claude's current role is the capstone of
a career that spans nearly 20 years at
numerous fortune 50 companies,
including senior leadership posts at j
Walter Thompson and publicists in London.
Uh, her success in guiding a employee
experience, client relationships,
global brand strategies,
operations and management, uh,
is driven by an abiding
passion for creating spaces
in which people can thrive.
Please join me in welcoming Claude silver.
Thank you.
Really good. Thank you. Thank you for
being here. Um, quick housekeeping. Uh,
please silence all devices and we will
have some time for Q and a at the end.
Uh, since we're recording, it's very
important that if you have a question,
please ask it at one of the
two mikes in the aisles. Okay.
So for people in the audience who might
not be familiar with Vayner media, um,
what would you say is the
company's mission and how
is that different from other
companies in your
industry or other country
in general? Yeah, so we're
a full VaynerMedia is a
full service digital agency.
So we're really a creative shop that
marries both paid media creative and
strategy in the middle. I'm not
unlike a lot of other agencies that,
that you probably work
with for sure. And, uh,
Gary would say our mission is to build,
uh,
the biggest human empire of
all kind of all time. Um,
I'd like to be a part of that for sure.
But I think the,
the differentiator for us
is that we really do put
people at the center that we,
because we're an independent,
uh, independently owned agency,
of course we're,
we,
we want to make sure that we're paying
attention to our top and bottom line and
the growth there. But it is
really the people that fuel
all of that. And I really,
I, I personally think that the
emphasis that we put on people,
the emphasis that we put on culture,
the emphasis that we even
have a job like mine,
which is very different than a chief
HR officer, which we'll get to,
I'm sure. Um, that in
itself sets us apart.
I don't think it makes us
better or holier than thou,
I think it just makes us very different.
And it is something that is hard
to Grok sometimes that, yeah. Okay,
well are you just like Droga five or
are you like anomaly? We're different.
We really beat to a different drum.
And I think a lot of that is because
of who Gary Vaynerchuk is and, and, uh,
you know,
incredibly fast moving and
path that is known for hustle.
But quite frankly, he's got a
heck of a lot of heart. So, uh,
the term honey empire comes up frequently
in reference to Vayner. In your role,
can you explain what that
means? Yeah, I can. There's,
there's a lot of different breakdowns, but
I've, I've definitely honed my, my, um,
my verbatim. I think at this point
there's two different ways I look at it.
So p being people first,
that's obviously the honey that
is taking care of the people.
That is making sure that if
someone is having a bad day,
we're taking care of them.
If someone got engaged or married,
we're celebrating that.
And it is really the idea of
creating champions from one another.
The collaboration,
the um,
the emphasis on working together to create
the biggest honey empire of all time.
The empire of course is the,
is as much more of the success.
It's much more of the at the client
success, the personal success, the uh,
the agency shop success.
So that is one way to look at it.
The other way I like to
look at it as something,
actually I am going to use
this little Easel d mind.
Hopefully I'm writing big enough for
the, for the camera. But fundamentally,
if I think about how I, uh, how I look at,
at building strong teams and
a and building teams that
are sustainable and they
last a,
I look at starting with the connection
again, hopefully that can be re read.
So connection as human beings we are,
we are absolutely wired to belong.
We are wired to connect with one another,
connection plus trust.
So once I connect with you and I'm kind
of like in it with you, we start to,
we start to trust one another. I might
let my guard down a little bit more.
It might be a little bit easier with you
might share something about myself with
you
plus empathy.
So I trust now, but now I'm sharing
something. Maybe I'm sharing about, uh,
an issue I'm having on another team
or maybe I'm sharing something about
something, a family, a family issue
or celebration or something like that.
Connection plus trust plus
honey equals accountability,
which also is another way to say loyalty.
Longevity.
We want our people to be there
with us for the long haul.
We want Vayner people to be
with us forever. Quite frankly.
Gary will say that I want you to
work with me forever. Accountability,
longevity,
resilience.
Who doesn't need resilience
in these times? I mean,
things are changing. I'm, I'm,
I'm sure you already launched the,
you know,
three different products while I've been
sitting here with you today. And, um,
but digital, the world of digital
is changing every single second.
So you need to be able to roll with
those punches. And also, you know,
Gary is a disruptor. He's an, he's
an entrepreneur. I mean, it is,
he could say today, by the time we get
back, uh, we're not going to do that.
We're going to do this.
And we all have to pivot very quickly.
So resilience is really important, and
our teams and our people, accountability,
longevity, resilience, equal speeds.
This is the empire right here. Speed
is our number one KPI. People first.
Here are the feelings. Here are all the
things that I care about all day long.
Right?
And here's the empire,
the fact of how do we get
it across the finish line?
So I hope that answered the question in
a very esoteric way. Yeah, that's great.
Um, so you mentioned, I think you
probably get this question all the time.
How is your role as chief heart officer
different from a traditional chief HR
officer role? Yeah, I mean, I'm
not HR at all. I've, I've, um,
I've never been HR. In fact, I, I
started in 98, I think before Google,
before Facebook as a project manager in,
in San Francisco,
and then morphed my way into
the agency side on the client,
client facing side. And, um,
and then found my home in
strategy and a way, way,
way back when I was training to be a
psychotherapist. So human development,
human behavior is always
something that's really,
really fascinated me and
still does to this day. Uh,
that's kind of like everything
for me, how we work, why we work,
how we can work better. And, uh, so I've,
I've been a strategist for a
very long time, almost 20 years,
and I am not HR, not a, I'm not, I'm,
I'm certainly now HR and I'm more equipped
and more educated in the science of
HR and the benefits and, and, uh,
international visas and
laws and whatnot. But, um,
that's not my job. We have some
incredible HR people in the, in, in, uh,
the crowd right now that are on my team,
which is amazing.
And they really take care of,
um, the, the HR factor, the,
the science of it, the benefits, payroll,
401k's and, and really, really
the reviews, the review cycle,
all of those things as well. So my job
isn't, I mean, you, you would say that,
send that to Claude because she's
a head of HR, but, but I'm not,
I get to oversee that,
which is,
and I get to cocreate with people that
know more than I know in terms of HR and
he'll, Gary really sees himself as HR
because he's a people first person.
And so the synergy that he and I have
in terms of how we feel about people,
our belief in people,
um,
our gut about people is
really what created this role
and why we call it heart.
Because we actually think of HR,
which I have no idea what that
really means as hard. In fact,
we changed the name of
the department when I,
when I started to people and experience,
because after all,
that's what we're doing here. You have a,
um, a department of, you know, people ops.
It's very similar,
similar,
but the idea of human resources to me
is very foreign. I, I really, I don't,
um, I don't get it, but, um,
but if anyone wants to
explain those two terms to me,
I'm open so people can experience and, um,
and really I'm not, I'm not chief of HR,
but, uh, but again, we've got a great
team that, that takes care of that.
Excellent. So, uh,
one of the things you've called
yourself as an emphatic truth teller,
uh,
when you were describing what it was
that Gary needed to sort of scale what he
did for the organization as
the organization expanded, um,
what's the hardest truth
you've had to tell or,
or at least the hardest one you can share?
Sure. It's, uh, it's empathic. Empathic,
I think someone wants to call
me an empathic truth. Okay.
Maybe I didn't tell her his heard that.
Maybe it's an emphatic, I don't know.
I'm sure I, hopefully it's
enthusiastic, but, um, you know, it's,
it's hard.
It is a challenge.
I think sometimes to confront someone
with something they might may not see
about themselves.
Um,
it's hard as another human
being to take that step,
that bold step forward as a just
another learner in the world.
And to think that I see something that
they don't see. I'm by no means am I,
you know, I'm not a psychotherapist.
I'm, I'm not a physician.
So it's really difficult to get up the
gumption and want to shine a mirror in
front of someone. And I think that is,
that's a difficult thing that we all have.
However,
when we give feedback and when we
share something with another person,
it's really an active caring. So when I
don't do that, I'm really withholding,
quite frankly. I'm, I'm manipulating
someone's growth and development and, um,
the way I go about it is as,
as hopefully with as much grace tack and,
um, and you can generosity
of spirit as I possibly can.
But that is something that
I think is, is, um, is I,
you just have to step wisely into that,
into those shoes.
I'm cautiously of course, because you
never know how someone's going to react.
But if you,
um,
if you go into that truth
again with empathy, um,
and with humility,
my God,
then I think the door can open to so
much possibility and that's what it's all
about.
Possibilities there an example
that you can think of where, yeah,
telling that truth. There's an
example. I mean, when did I get here?
So I think an hour ago I was
in a room with a very senior,
um, senior account holder count
and our client service person,
and this,
uh,
this person was telling me that he has
been exploring his team for the last
three months and these are the three
buckets that he thinks are, uh,
wrong with his team.
So it's probably my age.
He's in his forties and um, and he,
maybe he knows more about life than I do.
I have no idea. But he and I have
had many conversations over the past,
I would say eight or nine
months about these, these, uh,
issues in his team and only
today he's bringing them to me.
So what I did say to him is,
you know, with all due respect,
I really believe that you've been
protecting your team this entire time.
There's no need to protect your team
and these three buckets that you just
shared with us,
it should have been shared with me nine
months ago because we could have fixed
it.
We didn't need to go through
all the rigmarole and all
the people issues and all
the, the hardship and all the missed
deadlines and all of those things if we,
if we just could get truth.
So that's probably the most
recent conversation. And,
and he took it as well as can be.
I'll,
we'll see what happens when I
get back to work. But again,
you go into it with, with
as much grace and, um,
and just generosity, you
know, I want to help him.
So your role was created to help preserve
[inaudible] culture while it grows
rapidly. We know a little bit
about that here at Google.
What are, um, what are the elements of,
is culture that you most fear losing
as you continue to expand and scale?
Yeah.
So yeah,
the role was this role was created to
scale Gary and he says to scale the
unscalable, which I think is a
phenomenal way to say it. I mean,
how do we scale culture?
That's the big question.
It's a question I get all the time in
a question. I'm sure you guys get it.
Almost 80,000 people and,
and wanting to maintain
Google across the world.
So our culture is really built on a few
different values that I can say over the
last eight and a half years are
pretty tried and true empathy,
which I will call heart speed,
which I would call hustle,
hustle and heart possibility.
We work for an entrepreneur and
everything really is possible.
There is a yes all the
time until there isn't,
but it takes a very long time to
get to the know if, if ever, um,
positivity. I mean, Gary
overindexes as an optimist,
I'm probably very close
behind him. And, um,
and winning competitiveness.
And those are things I believe are still
in our DNA absolutely over eight and a
half years. But those are things that we
need to continue to stoke the fire on.
So for example, let's take the
conversation that I just had.
That conversation was out of line and out
of touch with our culture because the,
the,
the winning was misguided.
The wanting to win was miss w the
wanting to win was, was Cayston fear.
That's not one of our values.
It's not how we,
how we use and foster our culture.
And so,
you know, and that's just talking
to one individual. Where is that?
Is that spread anywhere? I mean, so, um,
the most important thing that I'm doing
every single day is I'm talking to a lot
of people.
Quite frankly,
I'm listening to a lot of people
and I'm just collecting data,
collecting information.
I'm holding space to see what happens,
to see what comes out. And as I'm
speaking to people and collecting data,
I'm looking for patterns and I'm looking
to hear if I hear a similarity on one
certain team or if I hear a
similarity on a department,
even though the department
might be in a different country,
it might have legs in a different culture,
a different company start
different country. Um,
and so as I hear these patterns,
that's where we start to
deploy more people that are
what I like to call culture
carriers.
By no means as the title culture carrier,
although they should put it
in their signature, right?
These are people that really get,
uh,
but get a sense of the water that
we're drinking every single day.
It's not Koolaid, it's water, it's
pure, it's real, you know. Um,
and so in every office and certainly
in our offices here in New York,
which we have to, um, I've,
I can depend on and rely on using and,
and asking that person or that person or
that person to go take that person for
a walk or for a cup of coffee or go
have a little mini town hall with those
eight people who are just kind of crusty.
Um,
so that is something that is it
tea? It's like 24, seven job.
It's an absolute 24, seven job, which, um,
you know, meeting with people one on one,
having hangouts with people going,
you know,
I'll start a big round of office visits
next week in different countries and
different cities.
And so making sure that we have that
high touch at every single moment.
Obviously Gary is doing
the same exact thing.
He might be doing five minute meetings,
he might be doing a lot of texting,
but we try to cover and h and cover
as much ground as we possibly can.
And,
uh,
ensuring that the culture is still being
fed and fed and watered and so that we
can, we can have like new sprouts every
single day. I talk in metaphors a lot,
but that's what it looks like to me.
Quite frankly.
It's 800 people now I
think 805 people I think.
And it's a lot.
It's just a lot of heartbeats.
It's a lot of mouths to feed and
certainly don't need to explain that to,
to Google. But um, so we've got,
we've got a lot of learning to do,
but I do think that we've
implemented some, um,
some really good a tried and tested um,
abilities now.
Yup. Are there, in the run up to 800,
are there things that you feel like
you've sort of lost irretrievably? Um,
or,
or things that just couldn't,
couldn't survive from the smaller
scale to the larger scale?
I don't think we lost them. I think we
lost sight of them and then got them back.
That's what I think. So in terms
of growing, growing, growing,
and that's just for example, like the,
the talent team that's here. I mean they,
they,
there was a period of time and there's
only about five of them in all different
countries and New York, we've
got three, uh, three or four. Um,
but there was a time that they
were hiring hand over fist. I mean,
we couldn't bring enough bodies
into the offices and into our world.
And what we lost sight of was training
in what we lost sight of was the
orientation.
And what we ended up doing is throwing
them into a fire without giving them a
sense of what's in our DNA,
what's in our, what's in our,
our bloodstream and our water.
And, um, there were moments,
I would say in the last 18 months,
two years,
that you could feel the
ground start to not tremble,
but just start to shake a little bit.
Or the wheels on the bus just
start to rattle a little bit,
a little harder than I like. I like a lot
of speed, but it was a little much. Um,
and in those moments it's,
you know,
that's something that I talked to Gary
about and we talked to my team about and
we have to kind of do a full
court press in that moment.
There's some things that we're not
going to be able to retrofit and change.
But going forward, we know how
important it is to Orient, you know,
we have a week long orientation and how
important it is for that employee to
really, really connect, get a
sense of belonging, tried and true.
We want them here. You know, we've gone
through three rounds of interviewing,
maybe four.
And so when they come in,
we already have this incredible sense of
belief in them and it takes an employee
obviously a longer time to believe in the
org. But in those cases where we were,
we got lost a little bit. And so,
um, anyway, we've retrofitted.
And are there things that you find that
you can do at scale that you couldn't do,
uh,
when you were smaller?
That I actually believe in terms
of going back in time a little bit
back in time. It's not the right way to
say it because we can't go back in time,
but we can certainly go back and have
that conversation with that swath of
people that we may have
missed. Um, we moved to a,
we opened up our first international
office about 15 months ago in London.
And in doing so, we sent out x
paths to open up the office. Uh,
one of the things we
learned very quickly is an,
and I worked in London for for
a significant amount of time,
so it's something I knew,
but as an ex pat,
it's different with different glasses on.
Um,
it's so important to get locals in your
office and get locals in your office
fast.
Otherwise it really is like the
American invasion in many ways.
And that's not gonna work. That's
not going to work in another country,
but it's certainly not
going to work when you,
when you are a local and you walk in
and there's eight x paths and they're
telling you what to do.
So those are things that
we've had to look at and,
and reverse engineer as we go forward.
So, uh, we're just finishing
up our performance management
and compensation cycle.
Uh, African every company has
them in some form or another. Um,
but those processes, performance
management, compensation planning, um,
they're often seen as sort of
being directly at odds with uh,
the effort to create psychological safety,
a culture of trust.
How do you handle performance evaluation
and rewards without undermining the,
the honey empire? It's so
tough. I mean this crew right in
front of me that,
that uh,
that's on my team is and they're the ones
that take a little bit of the bruising.
Um, because there is such a juxtaposition
between we love you, we believe in you.
We want you, you have a home,
we want you here forever.
Here's 6% or you just got
all fives on a review,
on a review form. Cause we just got
out of our cycle as well. And uh,
but you're not getting, you're not
getting promoted, but here's 10%.
These are really hard conversations.
I don't have the answer other than so
much high touch and that means you know,
spending time with that employee,
going back to that employee,
letting them know we work
for them, working with their
manager, seeing how we can,
you know, if, if, if we're
not able to give them the um,
the salary increase that they were so
hoping for and it is 6% or it is 8% making
sure that what's in their review in terms
of their training and development or
their growth plans, we are hitting
immediately or as soon as we possibly can.
That's,
that's one way I think that
we can surround that person
or that cohort with as
much heart,
as much honey as we possibly can.
Spending time with Gary is always going
to be a benefit and it's weird to kind
of dangle that in front sometimes,
but it is so incredibly helpful when you
get that time with Gary and he's able
to, in his own words, really,
really hone you into the vision because
the vision is, the vision is amazing.
Like the,
the vision of what we're doing.
We're building an agency so that at some
point in time we can buy brands and,
and own them and create the
marketing and awareness for them.
Like that's awesome that there's not a
lot of agencies that are doing that. Um,
but it is, um, it's something
we need to spend a lot of time,
a lot of time with and a lot of,
um, not coddling and not pampering,
but just again, high touch. I
say that I say that phrase a lot,
but it is really what we do,
um,
from a resident on up to an SVP.
Hmm.
And in line with fat as,
as chief heart officer,
how do you,
how do you go about helping someone when
they're not succeeding in their role?
So when they're not
succeeding in their role,
we do as much of a three 60 as we can
first and foremost to find out is that
really true or is that just that one
person or that one manager from the top
down? That's like rabbi, Rabbi back
because that's not fair. Right?
So we really try to look at it in a,
in a holistic manner and get as
much three 60 as we possibly can.
We put people on performance plans
30 day, 60 days, sometimes 90 day,
um, in, in London. We
will extend that notice.
We will extend that a 90 day trial period
if we need to for another three months.
We want people to be successful again.
We've invested so much time
as you do too in recruiting,
finding that right talent,
bringing them in orientation.
I mean it costs a lot of money. Also talk
about the empire, you know, it's when,
so when you lose an employee,
it customers doubled,
tripled to get that next employee in.
So making sure that we're
giving them very specific,
clear ways in which to
improve is that's our job.
Actionable, measurable,
ways to improve. Otherwise,
like that's not fair, you know? So
we spend a lot of time doing that.
We don't have a lot of
people on performance plans.
I don't know if that's a good or a bad
thing. Maybe we're not looking at, uh,
looking deep enough.
But for the most part,
I think coming out of this
review cycle right now,
I can say that it's a very low
percentage and we're doing our best to,
to get people to get the seize up to
a B and to get the bees up to an a.
One of the things that we do have that
I'm super proud of is we have this alumni
program.
So if someone,
if we have a c that we know
will be in a somewhere else,
or if we have some of
those just not working out,
we're just not the right culture for
example. Or we just moved too fast,
we will do our very best as we let them
go to find their next interview to find
their next role. And so we can do that
based on Gary's network of course,
and getting and based on
the enormous amount of, um,
job requests he's getting in every single
day. Like, Hey, do you have a, Hey,
do you have a, and so we'll do our best
to do the networking and then set them,
set them up with that first interview.
So, um, one of the things
that I think we're, um,
we, we've noted in our culture and
that and that we're struggling with is
how do you, how do you
make a manager, right?
How do you take somebody who's a
tremendous performer as an individual
contributor,
um,
and either determined that they should
or shouldn't be a manager and then make
sure they have the manager skill sets,
which are actually generally
very different from the
skill sets that made them
successful as an individual contributor.
Um, what, what's your approach to,
to making managers?
So
we are in the process of figuring out
that training. I'll tell you, unlike,
uh, I should say not, not
unsimilar to many agencies,
you get promoted,
you just rise through a ladder and you
just get maybe like a higher salary and
more responsibility.
But there isn't a lot of manager
training and agencies probably due to the
nature of our work now it's incredibly
fast where the service of clients,
we have an output. Thank you
very much. So forth and so on.
And You keep on going on and on and on.
Management management training is
something we kicked off in January in
difference in different
forms. And that, that, uh,
that included our presentation training
that included a radical candor feedback
training that is now including,
um, a facilitation training.
But we are still figuring
out what is the right, what,
what does a Vayner media manager
recognizing that we want everyone to have
uniqueness and how do we go about having
that training? How do we go about,
is it one on one? I mean, obviously
experiential is the way to do for, for,
for I believe that we learn
faster when we experience it.
We either teach it or we experienced it.
So we're developing those
things right now. And, um,
I absolutely wish I had a magic wand and
we could make that happen faster. But,
um,
but spending time with people and really
figuring out what makes them beat,
what makes them tick,
kind of figure it,
helping them figure out kind of their
own human behavior so that they can be
that much more tuned into others,
I think is the key there.
All right. Um, I have a
couple more questions,
but I want to take a minute and just see
if there are questions in the audience
that,
yeah.
Hi. Hi. Um,
something that is so important.
Yeah.
I think hard to manage for a lot of
people that I know that you've done having
worked with you before really well is one,
found your passion and then secondly,
you found a way to get there.
Um,
I would just love, and I know you
mentor a lot of people in that way too.
I'd love to hear your perspective on that.
Tips and tricks of how you kind of found
value in this and navigated your way.
Thanks, Carrie. Yeah,
and I've worked, worked with each
other about 13 or 15 years ago,
so thanks for being the
first question. Yeah. Um,
so I love doing coaching
and I love mentoring and,
um, and throughout my years,
whether or not I was at this company or
that agency or running my own surfing
company, um, I've picked up a
lot of positive psychology, uh,
tips and tricks along the way and,
and Life Coaching and executive
coaching tools. And I, I,
I do a lot of coaching.
I called them white sessions.
Some people might call them
northstar sessions, but, um,
what I find is most important with,
with all people and all human beings,
is making sure that at some
point in our existence,
we were able to define
and touch our purpose,
our passion and our purpose
could be very different.
My one of my passions is snowboarding,
but my purpose has nothing
to do with snowboarding. Um,
so there's a difference there. But, um,
so I take people through value, values,
exercises. Uh, I really like
people to be big in the room.
That's something I say a lot.
So when they're with me and
they're in one of these 45 minute,
hour long sessions, what I say to them,
it's like, it's just us in the room.
So it'd be big. Like, tell me really,
what is the value you bring to teams?
Like no one's listening, just you and
me. Uh, then I'll look at their values.
Sometimes I even asked them what
they wanted to be when they,
when they were kids,
what do they want to be when they grew up?
Because I think when we go
back to the origin of time,
when we were just innocent and we
wanted it to be an astronaut or a film
director or whatnot, there's
a lot of truth in that. Um,
and sometimes there's still threads.
There's still like a red thread that
runs through from when you were a kid to
when you're an adult. Um,
I really ask people to,
it's a funny little corny question,
but to think about
in their most innocent of times,
brushing their teeth in the morning,
just who are they? Like, what
is, what is, what are they,
where's the resonance? What,
you know, are they, are they mad? Are they
like, when you wake up in the morning,
who are you, what, what type
of person are you? And then I,
so all of that together and we hopefully
we land on a guiding principle or a
mission statement, something that they
are really proud of and they can own.
And they put, I say, you know, put
that in your wallet or, you know,
put that on your laptop. Um, because it's,
it's unique to each and every individual.
And I really think that once, you know,
if I, if we're successful in this,
might take three sessions with them. Um,
they go back to their desk and they
can use some of that with other people.
I mean, that's how I see it. That's
how I'm scaling myself, quite frankly,
aside from the team,
if I'm having this incredible
interaction with another human being,
that they're going back to their desk,
their team,
their cohort, and they're able to, you
know, sprinkle their own magic dust,
you know, and that way
that we just, the, I mean,
the good vibes just keep, keep, keep
on going. But, um, that's what I do.
I just spend a lot of time
doing a lot of coaching and, um,
and just like creating space for people
to just be whomever they want. You know,
at Vaynermedia,
and I wouldn't doubt at Google as well.
We're teaching a lot more
than just fundamental skills
of how to use ad manager
or how did you know how to be an
incredible client service person.
I mean it's life skills. So
now, yes, you can teach empathy,
someone has to be interested
and open to learning.
You can teach self awareness
and those types of things.
So I think that's what juices me every
single day that I don't have to just,
I'm not just talking about,
um,
how to get this bottle into more
hands, you know, talking about why,
why would you even be interested in
getting this bottle into more hands? Hmm.
I've another question. Yeah.
Hi. Thanks for being here. Um,
I had an opportunity to see Arie speak
for the first time like two weeks ago at
a conference. Um, and as you all know
who probably worked for him, he has the,
uh,
energy and ability to kind of,
might drop on the whole room and make
people like kind of silence after I want
to be a part of what he's
doing or like it's so, um,
just engaging. So my question is
kind of on the recruiting process.
Do you guys find that a
lot of your applicants come
from like Gary v lovers who
just are a huge fan of him
and want to work for him?
Or like maybe even some of the recruiters
in the room who work at Vayner?
Like what is your guys's process?
Do you reach out?
Do you have a bunch of
people like that who apply?
I can only imagine
after hearing him speak.
So just wanted to know kind of what the
recruiting process looks like for you
guys.
Cool.
Keep me, keep me honest team.
But um, he's, he's absolutely,
in fact he's contagious. I mean that
energy and the mic drop and the,
and the realism of him is like
something you just want to be around.
Cause there's not many people out there
like him, uh, at least that are um,
that you see their content every
single day in every single way. So we,
I would say it's, it's split.
We obviously, you know,
we hire for skill set fit
and a culture edition.
If you wanted to Gary's inbox right now,
you would see,
I'm sure probably 300 people that are
like, I will work for you for free.
And that might have just
happened in the last eight hours.
By the time we get to
eight o'clock tonight,
there might be another hundred and 50
that just want to work for us for free,
which is, that is amazing. I just
like incredible and an honor.
Are those people the right
skillset? I Dunno. You know,
and that's where we have to start calling
through some of those cvs if we get,
now we have specific recruiters
that are looking at just media,
video production account,
project management and whatnot.
Every now and then we'll get sent one
of these people to have these people.
Or Hey, you know, the owner
of the new, uh, the New York
jets has a son. Here you go.
Um, we have, uh, so we, we have to look
through those incredibly carefully.
Of course we'll give someone not an at
bat or at an interview, that's for sure.
If they are a student will help, hopefully
get them into our internship program,
which is in the summer.
If are just coming out of university,
maybe we can get them in as a
resident. Again, the skills are super,
super important because we move so fast.
It's, it's not charity, as Gary would say.
He says a lot. It's just like,
I mean, what are we doing
here? Like we're working,
we're here to work. We're here to, we are
here to hustle and to be the, you know,
the biggest human, uh, human agency
in the face of the earth. But, um,
we really need to take our time and
go through those cvs and that's,
that takes a lot of time.
And then we have to make sure that we're
interviewing really, really carefully.
Otherwise we could just get a, you
know, a lot of Gary fanatics and,
and maybe not a lot of the specific
work that we need to get done,
but it's always fun to see those
emails come in. A lot of fun.
Chairman. Hi Erin. Hi.
Question for you. Um,
as Vayner media focuses on building
a honey empire or it more of the work
environment that has more heart
involved in getting more comfortable and
connected with your employees to make
them more productive. And as you know,
Google completely sense
itself in that way as well.
And where we're culture is huge.
Diversity is very important for us, um,
for the benefit of our team and employees.
Um,
can you talk about a time where
you using your approach towards,
um,
connecting with your employees that have,
that have made them more
productive and so you can say, yes,
this is something more scalable.
And,
and do you implore other companies or
other agencies for that matter, um,
to kind of employ employed
that approach as well?
Yeah. So let's see if I'm, if I'm
tracking correctly, what I, what I,
what I think you're asking is
a little bit of the training that
we do with our employees that are,
is basically kind of geared a little
bit towards the performance and their
success. So you know, the
honey and the empire portion,
maybe like looking at this or looking
at what I was talking about in the
beginning, which was putting
people first and if you really,
really hone in and deploy as much empathy
and care and Tlc and generosity and
giving to employees that the output is,
I mean you,
you just get 10 fold more of the output.
Um,
so we do a lot of, we, we,
we spend time doing a lot of small
town halls, size of this room,
uh, town halls where I
will be, I will just take,
I will field questions that
come at me about our culture,
about changes or more transparency.
I'll do that because I fundamentally
believe we need more communication
throughout the agency.
And I should say I started at the
agency as the SVP on the client side.
And so I can fully remember for
those 18 months I was there. I was,
I was thinking, Gosh, we need more
communication from leadership.
We need more communication
from leadership. And now
that I'm in leadership,
it's something that I
think about all the time.
How can we increase our transparency?
How can we make sure that we're delivering
on the promise of the honey empire?
How can we, how can we make
sure that we're delivering
that and development that,
um, that we, that we also promised?
So spending time with people is super,
super important. I've already said that,
but, um, making sure that I'm coming in,
you know, it's, it's funny,
so much of what I do,
it comes so naturally to me.
And that's the great thing because I'm,
I'm living my purpose to caries
to Carrie's question. I'm able to,
my purpose is to fill this,
facilitate growth and change and,
and people and companies and teams and
be a team builder and be of service.
And I'm able to do that every single day.
But I realized not everyone
is able to do that. So, um,
me showing that I think
it's really important that,
that everyone knows that I work for them.
No one,
there's absolutely no one
that works for me. Um,
and I will give whatever I possibly can
to help someone over that finish line or
help someone from the 10 yard line
to the 30 yard line, yard line. Um,
and that takes a lot of
time and energy and effort.
But I think that's the wonderful
thing about being in a company,
especially run by Gary where, you know,
he wants to buy the New York jets.
And so we function as a team in many,
many ways and making sure that
we're deploying to your point,
deploying as much of that honey
and the empire, uh, internally and,
and hopefully there's a trickle
on effect in other companies.
Yeah. Yeah. Um,
how do you scale that you go back
afterwards and are you able to scale that
dynamic to say this actually works and
it's actually making our employees more
productive? How do you scale that? Yeah,
the scaling question is such a great
question for us. I think at this size,
at the 800 mark, um, because
as I look out on the,
on the landscape,
it's not any,
it's not anything I'm going to
be able to do alone. And it's,
and it's something that
my team can certainly do,
but they're going to need
extra reinforcements very,
very soon because we can't be in every
place at every single time. And, uh,
in order to track back and see how that
employee or that cohort of people as a,
you know, if there are,
um, move, if, if they're,
if they're needle has moved since we
last trained with them or we lost spent
time with them,
it takes a lot of time and energy and
it takes away from something else that
we're doing that might be
extremely pressing. Um, so
it's, it's really, I, you know,
leaning on the culture carriers that
we've built right now to kind of be the
finger on the pulse for me when
I can't be there or for Gary. Um,
and making sure that we can track back
and there is something to measure.
But growth is something that we can, we
can feel, I mean, you can see it in the,
you can see it in the water,
you can feel it,
you can certainly feel it
when you're with someone.
And especially because we
have people that stay with us,
the longevity for a long time.
So you can see how they've EBD
and flown throughout their,
their tenure ship at Vayner media.
And we really use them quite frankly,
to help other people grow
and to make sure that we are,
um, going back and, and,
and I'm tying up any loose ends that
we may have missed. So it's really,
it's really a human, it's
really human effort. I mean,
thank God for Google and Google docs and
Google forms because that's what we run
on running. Um, it's, it's,
it's human effort. And, uh,
at some point, you know,
we're starting to assist,
systematize much more now that we're
a, we passed the 700 people. Mark,
thanks for the question.
Okay.
Zoom out a little bit of the previous
question asked around diversity and
inclusion in two dimensions.
So one is,
especially in the creative side of the
agency, business diversity has been
a massive problem in this part of the
industry within LGBT people of color are
dramatically underrepresented,
underrepresented in every creative agency,
every creative department
inside companies.
I'm wondering if you
could talk about your,
your point of view on sort of like how
you acquire that talent to you sort of
have a specific lens for that or not.
Um,
and then something that I think it's very
personal to a lot of Googlers is also
how once those people come in, um,
they do feel that sense of connection,
trust and empathy so that think she'd
feel included and want to build that sense
of loyalty.
Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
It's actually one that I love
digging into because as you said,
we're all trying to figure it out.
Um,
mapping the macro to the micro Mapi a
macrocosm to the microcosm is much more
difficult than I would've ever known.
Um,
as I'm now looking at it from the top
down and also just like being on the floor
a diversity and inclusivity is,
and they are different things of course.
Um, it's one thing to have
I diverse employee, uh,
nasty if you will,
but then to deploy inclusivity
and the belonging is,
I think that's almost more challenging.
So one of the things that is extremely
important to us is creating a safe space
where people feel that they can bring
their whole self stork and that means
physical safety and psychological
safety. Absolutely. Bar none.
We were talking about this earlier,
it's like literally on my head every
single day when people were new,
when can't,
let's start with the candidate experience.
When you are a candidate and you walk
in and if you are a person of color and
you aren't seeing any other people of
color, that is, that cannot feel good.
But there's just no way.
If you are a female and you
are being interviewed by males,
there's no way that feels good either.
So I mean that's,
that's just even talking about like a
white female of privilege, you know.
So making sure that we have as much
diversity out of in our office is in our
offices is really,
really fundamentally the most important
thing that we can do every single day.
And that means hiring,
like hiring the best person.
Of course we're going to hire the best
person that comes our way. Skillset,
culture edition.
I like this idea of making sure or trying
to make sure that our values with that
candidate and that candidate
or in the same zip code.
It's something I was just sharing
with the team the other day.
I don't expect your value in my value
to be completely apples to apples,
but I would like them to be similar that
I think the value piece of it I think
does open up the, um, uh, is a,
gives us a little bit more of an ability
to widen our net or cast a wider net
when we are looking for those candidates.
Um,
back to creating a safe space where people
feel like they can bring their whole
selves to work.
If you are a person of color,
you want to see more people of color.
If you are Lgbtq,
you want to know that we have a private
group. If you have a learning disability,
are you dyslexic?
Like myself?
You want to know that we have tools
that you can use. Um, all, you know,
if you have a physical handicap,
like you want to be recognized for
that not as an other and an outlier,
but that we can embrace you and,
and take care of that. So, um,
you know, the 3% conferences
going on right now up the street.
And one of the things I love about what
they've done there is they've called
attention to the fact that diversity
is so few and far between and creative
agencies.
Um,
the idea of finding that other,
especially on senior level creative
positions is really challenging.
It's really challenging for us. I'm
happy to say I don't have the, we don't,
we actually don't have stats
on multicultural diversity
because people can opt
out of that question. So what makes
me happy is when I walk around,
when I walk across the floor
and I can see just difference.
And I don't mean difference,
but the Max,
I mean difference with a Capital d because
that's, this room is different. Um,
it's something that is just
so incredibly important. I,
I can't even stress that enough.
It is,
I don't want to even say it's my favorite
question to answer because I don't
have the answer, but is my favorite
thing to kind of chew on all together?
Um,
and you know,
does that mean where we need to
learn lean in on the four d is more,
do you mean there's,
there's,
there's pockets in the city and pockets
and Chattanooga and pockets in schools
that we can lean on to
get different talent. Um,
it's something we certainly do with our
residents and our internship to really
like make sure we're casting that wide
net and able to mirror the macrocosm of
this, you know, this world. Um,
and it's something we haven't,
we haven't solved for yet.
It is a work in progress and uh,
but something that is so near and dear
to like what I'm doing back to Gary,
like what are we doing here?
Like we have to make sure that we are
finding talent that represents this world.
You know, and one of the
things I'm proud of that, uh,
back at work is that we have squads,
we used to call them tribes in fact,
and we took away that word tribes
because of the cultural sensitivity.
But we have squads and I like to use
the word cohorts quite a bit. Um,
and there was a squad that is called
the Amigos squad and they found it each
other. They found each other. They
founded this group first and foremost,
to be able to market to a Latinas
and Latinos and the Hispanic culture.
And now they've really a,
there, it's an inclusive,
it's an open door group and
it's an inclusive group.
But it's one that keeps me very, very
honest about what we're doing, about, uh,
diversity and inclusivity. And, um, so
I'm happy. I'm happy. We have that and a,
and a and still a startup quite frankly.
So thank you for the question.
And I'm open to any ideas,
uh,
to chomp on for, you know, how
we solve this. Yeah. Thank you
Tom. Passionate about that. Yeah, come on.
So,
um,
if you're successful in making your
workplace a place where people feel
included, feel at home, um, what's
your approach to work life balance?
How do you make sure that, uh, you know,
is there a danger of tipping that too
far where some people might fail to a
build or maintain their
life outside of work?
So the sarcastic me says to you, is
there such a thing as work life balance?
I mean sarcastic and slightly
true. Um, what, what I do is,
is by no means is it 24, seven,
but I'm, I'm working quite a bit.
Um, and I'm okay with that
because I've chosen this job,
what I,
I've actually turned over this idea
of work life balance for the moment.
And I look at energy management and that's
kind of the term that I look at and I
try to share a lot more of with um,
with our employees.
We have 80% millennials. So that
right there, and it's is an,
we're an agency so that is as cut
throat as it gets. I mean, you are like,
you are beholden to a client.
Uh,
and that means you got to get that out
when you said you were going to get that
out, you know, unless you're going to
answer the phone tomorrow with like,
you know, client breathing down
your neck. Yep. Which happens also.
But this idea of energy management is
something that makes more sense to me
today rather than a work life balance.
Unfortunately, or fortunately,
energy management is really being,
uh, aware of how you're feeling,
where your anxiety level is, where
you're at, where your anxiety level is.
Are you at Code Red?
Because if you're a code red,
we need to like figure out how to get
to pink or how to get to it like an an
orange.
Um,
setting up little milestones
across your day to then celebrate.
Take a break. So you're going to
work for 10 minutes. I'm sorry.
You're going to work for two hours on
this one project that you're working on,
this one spreadsheet or this one
deliverable. You're going to, you,
you're going to get to a stopping
point where you know, you can get up,
take a breath and you can go check
Instagram for 10 minutes. You can go out,
walk the high line, you can go for a
cup of coffee, you can go out to lunch.
Those are things I think going back
to my project management roots,
I think they're really, really
important. I think of, you know,
if I'm looking at a Gantt chart of my day
and where my energy tips and falls and
after lunch and whatnot, just being
super, super aware of, um, how,
how I'm feeling inside and how an
employee employees feeling inside and how
that's manifesting, whether or not
that's manifesting physically and I'm,
you know, maybe someone's grinding their
teeth are getting really upset or uh,
or how that's just manifesting
inside with, you know,
not feeling good enough about yourself
and feeling a extremely competitive with
that other person or Gus,
you heard that person's getting 10
k more and you do the same job like,
so managing,
managing one's energy is super
important right now. Yes,
having work life balance is like a dream.
I think that if any of us can go back in
time and clock in and clock out as some
of our parents did or work that eight
hour day with a half an hour lunch break
as some people do in
Europe, quite frankly. Um,
that is kind of utopic and
there are places to do that.
Um, I can't tell you that agency life is
that place right now. And maybe it maybe,
maybe as we see more a remote working,
you do that really well. I mean,
does that extremely well. Um, but agencies
are funny because for the most part,
you're in roles that you need to be,
you need to be present on a floor for,
you need to be able to look
across that desk and say, Hey,
will you look at my deck for a second?
There is such a collaborative, um,
Yin and Yang there. So energy man.
Uh, so work life balance is, um,
is something that I'm aware of.
Wish I had that answer too. Uh,
but time management is where I'm really
trying to get more people to focus on
and be aware of just how they're feeling
in any given moment and when they can
just take a timeout, timeouts really,
really, really help. And we all, I mean,
we all deserve timeouts. Like,
what are we doing here? Yep.
Great. Well, thank you so
much for your time. Thanks.